[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make way for bruce arians head coach
of the tampa bay buccaneers coach good
to have you back on how would you
describe the atmosphere there in new
england this uh past sunday night
well it was definitely a playoff
atmosphere that's for sure it was uh
it was a little bit surreal but uh
i thought tom handled extremely well
what role do you play in a situation
like that i don't know how many times
you've been in a situation where
you have
you know something like this a
homecoming a reunion of sorts and you're
talking to you know your quarterback
yeah i think for us the whole message
all week was you know we got to bounce
back as a team having lost to the rams
uh it's a team sport it just happens to
be time brady's return to new england
but we're playing the patriots and uh so
we kept that team message all week and
uh
and tom did a great job of keeping his
feelings uh under control all week and
and uh
we didn't play very well but we won the
ball game
why were you so annoyed with the the
hype heading into this
because this is a team sport
you know tom brady didn't win seven
championships
the team won him you know the bet the
patriots want him the boo he didn't win
the championship here last year the
bucks won the championship he's the
quarterback but uh we try to make this
thing a singles man sport too many times
and uh
bill didn't win all those championships
he coached the team that did
and i think we're losing sight of
football being a team sport
what did you think of uh the decision
that belichick was gonna go for the
field goal and not go for fourth and
three uh how what was your reaction to
that in uh in real time well i thought
it was a perfect call i watched nick
folk knock that thing in with heavier
rain and warm ups from 60. so i was very
very nervous i i knew he could make that
kick and i thought it was a perfect call
by bill to do it
see i was surprised because even if he
made it he's still giving tom the ball
with 55 seconds to go and two timeouts
and i like your odds
yeah i think for for for him and for me
also that's time to play defense
and uh you know for our kicker we'd have
to get all the way to the 35 and uh
with two timeouts it wouldn't be
impossible i would like i like our
chances too but uh
i want to be winning when that thing i
don't want to lose it on a fourth and
three
what do you think of replay
uh
i love replay
i don't like the interpretations of the
rules anymore
you know things that were things that
were something for a hundred years
aren't the same anymore we're changing
rules uh every single year
that that have been rules forever and uh
so yeah i love replay i just cannot
stand the interpretation of some rules
i'll say it so you don't get fined i
thought you got screwed uh
the jacoby myers catch coach
yeah i mean i don't know you know
there's now a third element to a fumble
and i thought a football move was
running towards your goal line
so when you catch it yeah you you might
bobble it but then you got total control
for two steps and somebody punches it
out from behind that's a fumble it
always has been a fumble now it's not a
fumble so i i just throw my hands up
anymore
how did we watch football coach back
when we were younger when you know we
didn't worry about what's a catch and
ground causing the fumble or a football
move i mean
this
it feels like they're adding instead of
subtracting
oh totally totally trying to you know
what does it catch what's a fumble hell
what's the touchdown
uh i don't know what uh
you cross the boat goal line with the
ball in control of your hands is a
touchdown but
you know i i i'm not on the competition
committee anymore but uh yeah i'm not
i'm not in favor of some of the new
rules i think the taunting thing has
gotten out of control already i don't
know what taunting is and isn't coach
yeah i mean i think we all know what it
is
but it's not
jubilant celebration or
talking a little bit of crap i mean
uh
it's it's the
over the over the top jumping in
somebody's face but uh yeah i mean we
we've gotten to the to the point now
where we're trying to officiate
everything do you talk smack during the
game
non-stop
like but who are you saying it to
uh referees players
you're saying it to the opposition if i
know the guys yeah like for instance oh
for richard sherman i love now that he's
on my team i can't believe it
we talked more crap against each other
for all those years in arizona
and uh and some of the other guys that
that i know and uh you know uh so yeah
it's that's the fun part of it
how would you sum up what's going on
with your secondary right now
uh it's a it's a hospital ward i mean uh
we've probably had possibly one starter
this week and uh
three guys that got here
a month ago so
ty bowles will do a hell of a job he'll
have him ready to play and uh yeah
injuries are not an excuse in this
business talking to bruce arians third
season is the buccaneers head coach
do you consider belichick the best nfl
coach of all time
i think one of the top three for sure
you know i've got great respect for don
schuler and chuck noll uh i think coach
belichick's right there with him what
does he do better than everybody else in
the modern game
i think he takes away your strengths
and he knows your weaknesses and he
tries to take them away too i mean he's
defensively um
they've been as hard to go against as
anybody that i've gone to in my 27 years
i talked to carson palmer yesterday and
he said
tom brady has seen every kind of
defensive front he's seen all of that
but belichick still found a way to
frustrate him
uh did did you sense that
yeah yes and no i think we played we
played offensively as bad as we could
play as a group of receivers and and
people doing the right thing and being
in the right spacing
and tom was very very careful with the
ball but
they did a great job of taking some
things away but they don't take
everything away and you got to find out
which one it is
gronk's injury uh
ribs now punctured lung what's uh what's
the outlook best case scenario for him
yeah the lungs all cleared up and uh so
now it's just gonna be pain tolerance
and uh i think there's concern about one
of the ribs as far as
being displaced so it's day to day
take me back to when you were seven and
five last year late november what
happened
was there anything that you go i could
put my finger on it that happened that
changed us
yeah i think
it really was halftime of atlanta
you know we we talked about all the
things we wanted to improve upon over an
open date we came out we beat minnesota
but then we're 17 nothing
and it was hey we gotta attack
and we're gonna put
i told byron
all those home runs on that sheet call
them all
call them in a row we're attacking we're
not going to stop attacking
and same thing with todd on defense
we're going to attack
we took that mode and we just never
stopped it you know we started pushing
the ball down the field offensively we
started getting after people more on
defense and playing to our strengths and
uh
and
tom really played extremely well uh and
our team did we cut the penalties out
we just played really good team football
can you explain the difference of a
spread offense and the west coast
offense
the west coast ones always baffled me
because i don't know where that came i
know bill walsh's offense you know and
uh but
people have evolved the spread i think
the spread is is the read option to me
you're you've got four receivers spread
out all over the field and the
quarterback's going to read
the the option part of the run game and
the rpo part of it the college offense
that some teams are running now in the
nfl but the west coast is um
that was a two-back set that no one has
anymore so i don't think there is a west
coast offense out there there's a lot of
the terminology yeah
that coaches are still using coach
walsh's terminology but
they're not running the west coast do
you sample from college
uh for us it's what what do your players
what what abilities do they have
how can we maximize their talent and um
just put the plays in it that work for
them
uh
if there was an open draft and i give
you the first pick
of all these quarterbacks under age 26
hypothetical
so i i got justin herbert kyler murray
joe burrow josh allen mark jackson
patrick let me take my homes out of this
trevor lawrence
uh
probably justin herbert right now
he's playing as good as anybody and you
know he's got he's got the
all the measurables of of what great
quarterbacks have always had
you know he's got the height the arm the
speed uh the size and
so i don't know if anybody's playing any
better than him right now even patrick
but also coach you know one thing
one thing for sure is that
there for about eight years we went
through the flux of no quarterbacks
coming out of college
now with all the passing leagues in high
school and all you're getting the
quality of quarterback play coming out
of college now is way better than it has
been i mentioned this about 20 minutes
ago it feels like the nfl experts will
talk themselves out of somebody like
lamar jackson well he can't do this
kyler murray he's too short
and and that's dangerous the analogy i
also made was like steph curry if you
saw him in college you go he can't play
in the nba or steve nash he can't play
in the nba what why is it that we talk
ourselves out of something instead of
looking at the positives to say this is
what they they do so well that
overshadows that
yeah i think that's the world today you
know what i mean dan i mean uh
everything's negative
you know everything let's find the
negative part of it and not the positive
part of it and uh
for me i've always coached the way that
everybody's got a talent now let's let's
make sure that we build those strengths
and
and maxim you know
ensures weaknesses get better too but
let's build on the strength everybody's
gotta
how many hats you got
oh
my wife gets pissed every day because
there's a stack on this drawer there's a
stack so put the damn things away
somewhere i got a drawer full i don't
have any more room in the drawer
are you superstitious
uh
i swear i'm not but i am
[Laughter]
if you win with if you lose with a hat
like the the hat you wore with the rams
do you get rid of that
oh it's gone it's gone
how about the super bowl hat
uh it's it's up on the shelf by itself
oh yeah yeah i would i would i'm
surprised hall of fame didn't ask for
that
uh they actually did they got they got
the whole thing the shirt the hat
everything
and uh i really wanted to keep it but
i'd rather have it there hey great to
talk to you coach and uh good luck
against the dolphins this sunday we
appreciate your time as always
oh you bad dan always a friend that's
bruce erians